more choices are available for millions
of people who rely on the EpiPen for
life-threatening allergies we reported
last August how the EpiPens price soared
more than four hundred and eighty
percent over seven years to cost more
than six hundred dollars it had a
virtual monopoly and accounted for 94
percent of epinephrine auto-injectors
just 26 percent of prescriptions filled
today are for the brand-name EpiPen Anna
Warner shows us why there's still
confusion over the treatment and its
costs Anna good morning good morning
well this device the AVI queue might be
the best example of those confusing
prices some patients prefer it over the
EpiPen because of its small size and
internal voice guidance system the
listed price for a two-pack $4,500 but
most patients aren't paying a penny of
that leading to the question who is this
is the new avec you things have changed
in the years since we first visited the
henagar household in the suburbs of
Indianapolis two of the six children
here have severe allergies and last year
at this time parents Justin and Lexi
were unhappy about the prices for their
epi pens six hundred bucks for a two
pack we weren't really anticipating it
being six hundred dollars under
increased pressure from patients and
lawmakers Milan was forced to explain
the price hikes you think they were
charging too much at six hundred sir the
we believe it was a fair price and we've
just now lowered that price by half
Milan launched a generic version for
$300 and boosted a coupon program to cut
patients costs CVS Pharmacy then offered
a different generic injector for $109
then this past June the henna Gers got a
letter from their insurer they are no
longer going to be covering the EpiPens
they will only cover the generic version
so they have taken these completely off
of their plan but at their pharmacy
generics were out of stock that's when
they looked at the AVI queue this is
very personal for us Evan and Eric
Edwards invented the AVI queue after
growing up with severe allergies we
carry it
in our pockets everyday everyday one of
course you're supposed to carry two all
right so I have that as well it's
smaller and comes with its own voice
instructions basically anybody who picks
up the device is able to have a voice
guiding them what do I do next I think
that's key it's all about confidence and
we saw hesitation that one is a lot
bigger so this one's a little easier to
hold Lexy henagar liked the product but
not the price the AVI cue lists for
forty five hundred dollars so that was
kind of disappointing they actually
called me before they filled my
prescription to ask if I wanted them to
go ahead and fill it but drugmaker Kaleo
stepped in with its affordability
program and the family's out-of-pocket
cost went to zero how is that possible
Kaleo CEO Spencer Williamson the pricing
and reimbursement system in this country
is broken and we're committed to always
putting patients and families first you
have a drug that has a $4,500 price how
do people get that for free so it's an
access model built for patients and so
the way our program works is that anyone
with commercial insurance whether it's
covered or not even a high deductible
plan they'll get it for $0 but Richard
Evans a pharmaceutical industry analyst
from SSR health is skeptical the only
insure that's gonna say yes to a $4,500
claim for an epinephrine device in the
world where you can buy them for $109
because the one that hasn't figured out
the game yet the game Evan says to gain
market share a company can give away
most of its prescriptions for free and
hope the insurers who do pay those
higher prices make up for it it's an
insane system no rational designer would
sit down with a clean sheet of paper and
say you know what let's do it this way
but somebody in that system somewhere
pays for that high price so many plans
cover the product because it's the right
thing for their patients and their
physicians and they're very enthusiastic
about it where planes don't cover it the
entity that steps in and pays is Kaleo
patience like the henagar say they'll
take any break they can get up until now
there weren't really any other options
for auto-injectors there very few so I'm
hoping it will help kind of even the
playing field and bring down prices so
how will it affect prices will analysts
say in this business competition can
sometimes drive prices higher as drug
companies have to get into this market
with pharmacy benefit managers and
insurers
those prices can actually go up where
you'd think they might go down because
the complicated nature of this now the
avec you return to pharmacies in
February after a voluntary recall in
2015 that was under a different
manufacturer and another EpiPen
competitor is set to hit the market
later this year so this market at least
keeps changing and we'll see what
happens next what's interesting is that
people may not realize that the EpiPen
expires and you have to keep buying it
you don't always use it because it's
really meant for a serious condition and
so you have to keep buying that thing
and it could the costs are out of
control it's hard for people and what's
interesting about this one is it beeps
and then it will start to talk to the
person so that way and then basically we
will go through the whole thing but for
children especially they say a child can
listen to this
right and they know what to do in a
panic situation so it's a different kind
of wrinkle in terms of how do you
address a problem of severe Alaric thank
you Anna for that I appreciate it